I'm standing in the booth and it's tight
in here because it's only made for one
but we've squished four of us in I have
my brother on one side and my twin
sister on the other and my mom is
standing behind me I'm too short to see
what she's doing and I'm only four years
old anyway so I'm a little bit antsy so
I started ducking down beneath the
curtain to check out the feet and listen
to the voices and I ducked down again
and I popped back up and I ducked down
for a third time and then there's a
bright flash play cool that had nothing
to do with me but sure enough when we
walk out of the booth someone asks my
mom for my name and information I have
been a political junkie for as long as I
can remember or at least since my star
turn in the local paper back in nineteen
ninety i was born and raised in New
Hampshire home of the first in the
nation presidential primary and by
middle school I was writing letters to
the editor on the issues of the day in
high school I was running for everything
Student Senate which I won homecoming
queen which I lost but I was no
shrinking violet and I fast forward four
years later and it's my senior year and
I'm at Bowdoin College in Brunswick
Maine it's my spring semester and I'm in
this awesome class 10 students 5vs5 all
geared towards running a campus-wide
election and my team knows my history
and they look at me and they say Val you
have to run you have to be our candidate
you would be awesome and in that moment
I froze I was so afraid of putting
myself out there of being a bad
candidate of losing and so
I said no it's not for me I'm more of a
behind-the-scenes type of person I guess
that was something I'd internalized over
the last four years you do it tomm you
would be awesome you'd be our candidate
and he was awesome he ran and he won and
I fast forward another month later and
I'm sitting in the area living room of
my college presidents house I'm there
for a meeting with his wife asking for
help to get down to Washington DC to
work for a female senator she's a
serious person she went on subsequently
to be a cabinet secretary under
President Obama and I'm staring at this
oil painting in the corner of the room
not because I care about it but because
she's just asked me a question Val would
you ever consider running for public
office no I say it's not for me I'm more
of a behind-the-scenes type of person
like a chief of staff and she says how
can you say that you care so deeply
about women being elected to office if
not you who I've been turning that
question over in my mind for some time
and i'm here today to challenge the
paradigm that women like me and women
like all of you are more
behind-the-scenes type of people not
candidate material and to the man in the
audience don't worry this is important
for you to because we're all better
served when more women run for office
and we have more diverse representation
so what's the problem what's the big
deal well in 2012 Congress held a
hearing on the very thorny issue of
reproductive rights and contraceptives
and to debate that issue they bought
they brought in a panel of experts to
testify before the committee
and I don't care where you fall on this
spectrum this cannot be the best way to
talk about this issue we have to do
better but let's level set where are we
we know that women make up roughly forty
seven percent of the workforce and we
know that in recent years they've
received roughly fifty seven percent of
college degrees but when we look across
the country women make up just twelve
percent of Governors offices and less
than twenty percent of Congress that
twenty percent by the way is an all-time
high and it ties us with an unlikely
friend and ally turkmenistan so how did
we get here we know that when women run
they are as likely to win as their male
counterparts and yet a 2004 brown study
found that men were seventy percent more
likely to indicate a desire to run for
office and I suppose that's not all that
surprising when you consider another
study that said that a woman has to be
asked seven times before she considers
running for office most men need to be
encouraged just one time and that
encouragement can come from the face
staring right back at them in the mirror
I get it it's hard to run for office
you're putting yourself out there you're
making yourself vulnerable it's messy
and there's mudslinging and truthfully I
talked to a US Congresswoman recently
who told me that she got nauseous every
day on her first campaign just thinking
about going out there and getting
herself out in front of voters but you
are the women of the GSB you've never
shied away from doing something hard if
not you who so I came to the GSB and I
had dozens of conversations with my male
and female classmates and i said i'm
going to take it local I've had
conversations many of you in this room I
think and I asked would you ever
consider running for office and more
often than not our male classmates said
yeah I'm definitely considering it 100%
or I haven't considered it but I would
be great and on occasion hell yes I
should be President what is the holdup
and more often they're not our female
classmates on the other hand responded
with it's not for me I'm more of a
behind-the-scenes type of person and so
I dug a little bit deeper and I did a
survey of close to 300 of our classmates
and i asked the same question would you
ever consider running for anything and
the response was all too familiar of our
male classmates that responded
seventy-seven percent all of you said
yes i will run for office someday I hope
to the women just forty four percent so
why does it matter these issues that are
being discussed in the political arena
are incredibly important we're talking
about health care education the economy
these are decisions that are going to
impact our lives and our children's
lives and our grandchildren's lives and
you know what when women run they are
really good at what they do because
studies have shown that they are two
times as effective compared to their
male counterparts getting a bill out of
committee and getting that bill enacted
but when women don't run so many voices
go unheard so what can we do we can run
there are tons of resources out there to
help you be successful dozens in
California alone and I'm standing up
here offering to be a resource for you
as well I spent close to five years
working in Congress before I came to the
GSB I've been up close and personal I
promise you are all qualified to serve
in Congress trust me and I'm here taking
my own advice because now I can answer
yes I am considering a run for office I
hope I will have the opportunity to
serve at some point in the future I've
come a long way from that college senior
I challenge all of you to do the same
and today I want you to take a
meaningful step in that direction if
you've counted yourself out ask yourself
why or why not you if you've never
considered it consider it and if you're
thinking about it at all let's talk I
have a really long history with
elections to everybody in the room
including the men if you've thought long
and hard about running for office and
ultimately decided it's not for you I
hope you will identify encourage support
and work for a really good female
candidate you are the students of the
GSB you are the best and the brightest
the most highly educated the most
well-connected you are the future of
this country if not you who thank you